[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
we are live oh do you even do the euro
oh hello everyone hello hey what's up
everybody welcome to our Far Cry 3
livestream while talking about Far Cry 5
yep
so in case you haven't seen Ubisoft
release their trailer for Arkwright 5 oh
my
I'm just getting ready to write into it
yeah I want to load the volume of run
these guys over do it god I can't see no
so we thought it'd be a good opportunity
to oh my god you're just didn't work out
help me we're just going headfirst into
Far Cry 3 here I lost my phone's I'll go
under
I'll hit myself in the water yep so
again we decide it was a nice tix
opportunity to play a little bit of Far
Cry 3 which we we did run a poll
yesterday asking people what their
favourite Far Cry was and it was
overwhelmingly three as well as a lot of
writing votes for for write-in votes for
four so we are playing three right here
line three know what none of you picked
two there were couple I actually picked
a Blood Dragon because that's the only
one that I only actually played turn
down the game option scenario saying uh
hopefully that tweet was aired that
message was after he where'd he turned
it down
shipping him now um yeah so we're
playing I like I like the Far Cry series
quite a bit um I would I didn't I think
I played a little bit of the first one
without much off like a dog but I really
got in with - I like - a lot I remember
being really underrated and so I was
really excited when three got him out
and then yeah like they've just kind of
kept going I didn't play watch for four
cuz I'm a little burnt down on it on the
open world games at the time and I'm
good alright well this is going great
I should focus on playing probably good
Dan is that Danielle dan you Danielle
asked this on console now we're playing
it on the PC although I'm playing with a
controller
just unplug it here we go
this good stream okay
vikrum media sorry he says I guess Far
Cry 3 is gonna be a nice addition to the
series you would probably be a better
person to mark r5 yeah to ask about this
but you know we we were able to see the
trailer and I went through it quite a
bit like frame by frame just to kind of
pick it apart um and I really it I
really do like to say I know that the
Far Cry series is known for being set in
these exotic locations like where's this
one like some Isle is an island off the
coast of Africa I believe I know for was
in Himalayas live was or primal was in
prehistoric era I'm not mistaken up and
she was in Africa I was in Africa Africa
proper so then for them to go and just
be like we're gonna set it in rural
Montana it's it's hello for somebody's
I've always been kind of fascinated with
games that are set in like just those
kinds of sayings like American just like
typical like America's suburbia right
yeah no totally I am I think the idea of
yeah like the whole thing about Far Cry
is like oh it's like exotic right but
will by American standards right yeah
it's like exotic and different but um so
the idea of setting it like right in
America's back door is like an
interesting yeah because because even
though okay so it is in America but the
thing is that is inaccurate as hell
sorry John
yeah a few the thing with setting it
there is that America people I think
people always underestimate how big
America is right and we're like in
between all these cities along like the
eastern West Coasters this hugest
area of land like a montana for example
is one of the largest states and in
between all these small towns and cities
there's just land of flames and grass
and kind of nothing there
I'm like okay staff is excute yeah we go
so in a sense it still is kind of exotic
and unknown right I think for a lot of
people it's pretty it's pretty exotic
Charlie wants to know did four have
co-op yeah four did have co-op so
presumably five will as well I think
that's the thing I'm most interested
about is that this trailer really
doesn't get into is how the gameplay is
going to work yes like the trailers mote
was pretty much just all story
the thing about for that a reason kind
of why I didn't really play it was cuz
everything I'd heard about it was just
like yeah it's a more polished better
version of three and I was kind of like
I kind of want something like a little
bit more than that said to this radio
tower let's go let's do a classic
Ubisoft objective here climb a radio
tower like yeah stuff like that like the
idea of like okay if I'm gonna play a
far cry 5 I'm gonna have to climb the
radio towel yeah I'm gonna have to you
know a lot of parts of the map and then
there's like the the checklist of
objectives like there's a there's a
formula that far crys had for a while
since 3 that I'm hoping far cry 5 can
start to get away from everything
my favorites too and the thing I like
about too is how to like 3 is very much
like a sandbox right and I think 5 is
probably going to be a sandbox but what
I liked about 2 is that choose like a
very oppressive sandbox what I mean by
that so uh you die very easily
everyone's constantly attacking you you
have malaria in the game so constantly
yeah so you can actually like pass out
from malaria you your guns always are
jamming on you like you want to pick up
if you pick up guns off of enemies
they're rusted and they'll Jam and then
you have to like like mash the button
when you're like reloading cuz you're
gonna lamb here's question from jeonbu
sri which is probably very similar to
what you're discussing right now he's
he's asking what's your favorite aspect
of Far Cry that differentiates it from
other open world
well and so in like a yeah like I sent
Tuesday's it was how it was just like a
very like impressive game like you know
you had to constantly like prepare your
stuff and you were it was a game where
it did its best to make you feel
unempowered um threes the three and four
kind of the opposite where it's about
making you feel empowered and in that
sense I appreciate the game's kind of
playfulness like this game is just like
really fun to run around in and it's
when it came out I would say that a lot
of it was definitely novelty at the time
where you had this pretty big open
sandbox with like really good shooter
mechanics yeah the ability to kind of go
in stealth or going loud kind of get in
vehicles and that's not quite as unique
anymore mmm but back back when like
three back when three first came out
this was like pretty novel is what you
will use this maybe like thousand in
nine nine eight or nine I want to say
see that again Wow
so also I play this game on mouse
keyboard so I'm still adjusting to the
controller controls here Charlie from
Bob yes I can see your comments I will
be monitoring chat I have in my area on
a youtube and twitch
Oh so if you have any questions for jean
luke and i just send them our way you
want to just do something do my best to
get get to them I was loved just like
doing like dumb things in this game so
yeah Heisenberg says he's anxious to see
how they dive into the the cult-like
aspects of five right yeah and like he
said he's hoping that they don't hold
back
which I don't from for what I know of
the Far Cry series I don't think they
will now if anything they go too far go
the opposite way they are the opposite
uh what's my another thing that like
three that everyone really liked about
all that's a good guy um
that's a rarity people really act about
three was Voss which is the main
antagonist and like when the initial
like trailer came everyone's like whoa
this there's like this really like
charismatic like crazy dude you never
remembers like did I ever tell you the
definition of insanity like everyone
remembers that mm-hmm from three but
when you actually play three
this isn't in the game that much and
like that was kind of the biggest
disappointment he also uh spoiler likely
use the game halfway through was
replaced by he's on the cover though
exactly and then he is replaced by a
different antagonist who's like far less
interesting like I remember that guy's
name is that's disappointing yeah it was
and so um that was the thing that with
Ford they were like okay we're gonna try
and correct this and they did we're
pagan min who is also a really good like
charismatic crazy villain in the same
vein but it but his own take for sure
Troy Baker did a great job
he's the antagonist throughout but again
he's not in the game that much like
there's some really good stuff at the
beginning and some really good stuff at
the end I've kind of like gone through
and watch that yeah but he's not in the
game
most employed on either the more yeah
exactly so there's this uh that is
something I want to see more like if
you're gonna have this like crazy call
and these crazy cult characters I really
want them to be a constant presence
throughout the game yeah and it
certainly looks like it will like the
the the guy doing the the monologue in
five in the trailer I assume that he's
the the main bill main villain right
yeah Joseph basically me and then I
think it's either one of his brothers or
one of like some some henchmen is like
featured throughout the trailer he has
like the seven deadly sins car right it
was alright body and he's like shown
like enforcing people force it's like
getting them into the into that could be
a good way of doing it is having a
multiple cast of like it's a every
single one of those characters on the
box was a different like and tagging it
like you know a lieutenant or whatever
is cult that you were fighting and they
all get their own kind of like crazy
moment that could work pretty well
yeah um cuz like you know three in four
don't really do that it's mainly just
like boss or pagan men I saw someone ask
what's the best villain of all far cry
so far um let me see if I could find
who's saying that sorry I miss your
comment was we were talking Oh DJ Nash
three K is asking that so uh definitely
Voss stands out the most to me
personally
but I also actually do kind of like the
jackal from - who's this like arms
dealer in africa and and he sort of has
this like tragic backstory that the
whole game is actually like basically
heart of darkness
yeah and so I kind of like what they do
with that one but again a lot of it is
done through audio logs and you really
barely interact with the guy yeah so
there's like a good potential there that
they don't really capitalize on so
probably I think boss is just he just
stands out to me - yeah I like I like
speaking of boss Alex just mention the
chat that he he just realized today that
if you've seen better call Saul the show
well there's a there's one of the main
villains in like the first season is
this guy named nacho and he is the actor
that plays vas oh no that's cool yeah so
i remember when i said when i watched
bear claw so i was like he's a great
character and then i go and see the
cover art for three I'm like that guy
looks really familiar and like he did
all the motion capture and everything -
so it looks just like him apologies
people I'm eating if it's too much oh my
crocodile says no bagel for you just let
me my bagel man I'm hungry I can I can
visit the mic when I'm eating there's a
lot there's a lot of a heat going back
and forth between Far Cry 3 and Far Cry
4 being better right yeah it's uh it's a
case of I think for is like a
technically better more polished game
yeah but you could argue that you know
like three did all of it first and four
just kind of is like just built upon
like that yeah it's this kind of system
it's iterating off of four off of three
so maybe it's technically a better game
in a vacuum but it might not that might
make it less special for some people so
I think there's like that fondness for
three ah I can't get up that way alright
taking a long way but I mean they happen
in this too but uh I'm
- had like fire effects I were like
really cool like you could use a
multi-tool and you could light a brush
on fire and it would just start to
slowly like engulf the entire like
hillside and that was really cool and
they carried over stuff like that in
this one I'll bet it make it didn't
emphasize it quite as much can you climb
that yep we're gonna we're gonna hoist
our zipline down I believe so I'm just
thinking of a just cause we just like
zip up there first I know right yeah
that you have to actually climb it here
yeah you play a game like a this is back
when this was still pretty novel - um
like a platforming and first-person well
much is that do the whole like ubisoft
climbing a tower mechanic yeah like this
was still like a pretty novel concept
and it wasn't really out plate and kind
of poked poked fun at by everyone which
is really what i'm hoping they they kind
of tone that stuff down and in five or
at least like come up with like
something new DJ - 3k is also asking
about which farcry do we think is the
lease is the less appreciated let's
appreciate it well nobody ever talks
about one
yeah that's it's funny because like I
had a friend back in like oh it was like
tilson for the game came out right yeah
yeah maybe I wasn't like a round there
I'm like around that era and like he was
super into a game like you just
absolutely loved it I remember seeing it
at the time and I thought it looked so
if I move has his fans and it was a it
was like a kind of a big deal for how
good it looked and sort of this open
Sandboxie levels which you know in this
spiritual successor that crisis which I
also quite enjoyed yeah also what dragon
I mean I feel like with Far Cry 3 it
being like it more of expansion right
kind of sound like it's saying is it has
his fans which I am one of them sure I
would say yeah once maybe of the one
least talked about choose oh my god
these dogs a real quick question Andrew
- Charlotte we don't exactly know if the
protagonist will be silent and
if apparently is customizable yeah
that's what that's what we're hearing
that you can actually make your own so
it it might be able to have voices but
at the very least you will have that the
set of the three characters that we're
showing off and the trailers like the
new character vignettes where you get to
know them a little bit better and
they're like fully voice you know they
have these nice personalities there I
think they're all really cool ah no well
there's so many dogs
I can wild thought I got them all okay
well I still have the map among so we're
good specials saying Red Dead and Far
Cry that's that's really interesting
because I remember when they revealed
the location of Far Cry 5 it was going
to be like in Montana and everyone was
saying oh why would they make a Western
with with Red Dead Redemption to like
right everyone I want to seemed it was a
Western yes because like a parent like
cuz when you think of like okay American
games like there's not that there really
aren't that many they're laid that
aren't westerns like that take place in
like the West right Oh No okay we're
actually it's never good at driving
these things
yep yep we're good oh no not good that's
going great
oh hey what's up oh boy all right we're
just gonna hey guys oh no dog
Nicolas prodromus would you agree that
Far Cry primal was a huge letdown
I didn't play primal um I know that uh
some people in our office including uh
Mike McCarty he really likes like primal
um so I mean again it has its fans I
wouldn't say I'm not so sure about
letdown per se it's an interesting idea
for sure like the idea of like hey we're
gonna make a fire card game and caveman
times is like a real interesting concept
HK fuel is saying get a new good uh yeah
you have another one other than the
pistol in the machine gun the bow and
arrow with only like three things out oh
my god stop shooting at me don't drink
and drive
also taro yeah let's uh let's get a
different gun after this buy some stuff
ok so how big is the island here pretty
big so you got a there's two islands
you got this island here and then you
got the second island here which opens
up in the second half of the game and
I'm not sure like the exact square
footage or like comparing it to the
other video game but I remember being
pretty decent like that's what you have
to time yeah right yeah oh for sure can
you quick travel anywhere yes yes you
totally can um okay we want to do it
enough of here you can click travel any
of these outposts
okay let's get my guys on fire why no I
okay well never mind just lay Liam oh my
god uh alright let's just fast travel to
a place probably vs. Blood Dragon which
is your Pig definitely Blood Dragon for
me but I haven't played primal so I
can't say but also there you go I guess
blood Ryan's Li a short little what
dragon gets in and out before it gets
too stale yeah I got to get they tried
to stretch blood right into a full game
it would have what kind of felt man to
me let's see here okay oh you can buy oh
you'll have no money I think's good I
don't have enough money no we were broke
can we sell an quick sell we got to get
money we're gonna get money and buy some
guns also I can Oh commander Jean
Shepard craft here as well she probably
was asking about the dog companions in
Far Cry 5 according to our one of our
editors Miguel concepción he has
possibly confirmed that there will be
dog companions that will like fetch you
are or fetch you like loot and attack
right yes that's not school I like that
as a mechanic
ooh so this container 25 room was there
Joey oh boy it's all diamond icon
yes Oh Marty's like we're playing on PC
with a gamepad yes yep which I am not
used to I mean you have a mouse and
keyboard right in front of you yeah it's
not a good mouse though um and let me
take a look okay so I'm plugged in yep I
split then I think it um I think it's
one of those games we have to like go
the options to forgive a to change it so
we're gonna just stick with this all
right that's gonna go some money let's
go hunt some take some revenge dogs yeah
I was gonna say revenge on the dogs and
also the crocodile that killed or
killed girls no I feel I got that crowd
about you go I got him I got him good
oh wow I am bigger video on this alyc
post right here is wooden stand
hey what's up everyone oh they were
friendly right maybe he's just trying to
repair their karma actually I think I
ran over a friendly dude oh okay let's
do this let's get this challenge let's
get the shotgun
let's kill us some dogs Cameron Hartley
were I don't believe we're using any
mods no it's just like straight up like
never engaged in the mod scene for three
I messed with the mob scene for two
which is fun because you can make that
game even more intense which is a great
but I've never done an climb up this
yeah never done three what are there
like some pretty good mobs for three if
you're if you're aware of any I would
assume so oh let me guess a chat like if
you guys know of any mods not that we
can download it yeah now that would be
right now I'm just kind of curious okay
are these dogs I'm supposed to kill
unless they're over oh there's a watch
them yeah well you have a camera that's
regal zoom in I love how the attention
to detail on the the focus points yes
that's pretty awesome ah I remember
thinking that was super cool no mmm hey
over here Chris a is asking Joey and
John Luke us yep
what Far Cry aspects were ahead of their
time you think honestly like I don't
know much about the game the series but
John Luke is play like quite a bit of it
yeah uh so for like the original I mean
visually and then also just sort of like
the open sandbox levels we're definitely
head of its time as far as to goes the
what the fire effects and graphics were
just like amazing but then also that
game had like a really cool attention to
detail trying to like keep that game in
world none of the other games have done
it sense but that game its map was an
actual in-game map you'd hold up your
character like hold
the matter which is really cool um it
doesn't it get kind of annoying after a
while
it uh I didn't find it annoying it's not
any less annoying than doing this okay
it's the same thing really
and actually Far Cry 2 heavily inspired
the fire watch people oh yeah that's
better they're huge fans where are these
dogs he gave me a shotgun and there's no
dogs oh are you in the wrong area oh
okay
they're like over there why would you do
I assumed it would be like right next to
each other
I'm sorry guys I haven't played far cry
3 in a while someone's asking about lung
goodness uh like how long these games
are oh no is long in his pastor Jerome's
lost brother I'm assuming they're
referring to a character I'm not exactly
sure pastor oh I think that's the drum
was that character in the yeah he's in
five think of all this is pastor Luther
ah I'm not I gotta be honest I forget
half of the characters in these in these
games so I cannot just follow the yellow
dot where is it it's like not on my map
anymore that's weird okay it's around
here
yeah oh there's dogs there they are
yeah one don't let me over well meets -
oh come on
Cameron Hartley says there's a there's
actually a mod where you play as I'm
swimming he says boss he says vans here
but boss oh and Jason is the bad guy oh
that's a cool mod I like that actually
hunt him down all right one more come on
how long this is the arms dealer family
from Far Cry 4 oh okay
Hey yeah no no Bobo Jones yes I was
hoping that blood drag would wouldn't -
for the the Twitter poll right yeah it's
a fun one now Andrew Gokul would will
you guys prefer a third person approach
to Far Cry I don't know I kind of like
it as a first break - it's like the
there's something about that I mean
especially like when it came out
most open-world games were in third
person you know GTA so having one that
was like in first person with like
really tight first-person shooter
controls it was kind of what made it
stand out at the time who these guys can
I get them
you know I do have foreign aid just toss
that in there yeah it's a directed okay
try going up thank you good right like
everyone did or there's a slide slide
again this is not like Vanquish we just
keep shooting boosting all around ah
every game should have a boost side like
vanquish okay
akaash vanjani sorry if I'm butchering
your game it's asking one Far Cry five
will release it is going to be released
February of next year which is a long
ways off oh it's not even this year no
it's not this year's February 27 stay
2018 oh it's gonna be a long wait more
pirates let's do it
way over there well let's quickly fast
travel here then thank you be in my bag
well for this cream cheese smells so
good
someone mentioned earlier eating on
stream
Nick fears and says this island would be
a pretty epic Jurassic Park spin-off
game I would love if the next frog I was
just like a drastic park game well I
mean well primal had dinosaurs right if
I'm not mistaken did it or is it not
or maybe I just think of Arc I don't
think part I don't think primal i
dinosaurs will have like prehistoric
stuff their release yeah add like ma'am
mammoths and like just almost godlike
dinosaurs
oh yeah like um I remember I mean like
Blood Dragon has t-rex dragon gems but I
just you know a little out there but I
want like yeah I agree like an
honest-to-god like Jurassic Park game
like you make it to the side room that
you for some reason is just littered
with dinosaurs that no one's ever
discovered I think that would be cool I
think that's the if they're gonna do
another like weird spin-off game I think
that's the one yeah we prefer our
Thursday livestream with Robin Peter
yeah I think they could play that Mass
camel still looks pretty good on piece
looks loose obviously for looks even
better
oh yeah Bobo says primals 10,000 BC not
65 million yeah exactly a little little
jump
Oh No I forgot how fragile you are in
the in these games
I haven't played them in a while no one
wants to fart my son remastered
malaria's dangerous uh disagrees so so
into would disagree that malaria's games
well I mean um as malaria is very
dangerous it's like you have that throw
off the whole game like you can't get
rid of it yeah you have to um you have
to have pills that you have to go get
and if you don't have them you can die
you'll just lose that game is very
oppressive like I totally get why people
do not like yeah but I love it I think
Mike described it pretty perfectly
yesterday we were talking about which
one we wanted to play you're saying far
cry 2 is the is the favorite for all the
hipsters which I would say is actually a
very accurate statement what am i eating
I'm eating a bagel
it sounds crispy yep toasted it golden
crispy as Liz I need to use a knife oops
maybe I should actually job you guys
should read my mission objectives these
guys are so bad at Far Cry I mean you're
not wrong okay what's that let's like
try and stop this out here all right so
we got a grenade which we will not use
right now we should try a knife the dude
so
let's say here oh yeah the next-gen
grass
oh I forget what the pointing in the
picture is does it like mark them or is
it just so it just marks them if you
just hover over um yeah I think you do
use the picture for certain objective
stuff you're taking pictures of things
oh no they stay marked hmm anyway also
there's the other main dude and there's
a dog okay so so you'd use knife just on
him first probably if I can just knife
him first and then just get the hell out
of there I might be good let's see if I
can abandon the chat says a Gunpla to
was interesting because of the condition
of the gun which was important yes yeah
exactly things like the gun wearing over
time and and so you'd be encouraged to
buy your own guns as opposed to right
there no no no no I would just say take
them out oh oh no oh yes good guy died
though but forget if that still counts
er if I it's gonna make me do it again
this is your first time playing Far Cry
3 it's my first time playing Far Cry 3
in years
hey I accounted and on the controller in
on a controller
I haven't played var Cry 3 since it came
out how much money do I got houses but I
can't hold any more than that what then
how do things cost more than you gotta
get upgrade your wallet oh my god right
so can we just craft like wallets eat
the crafting we need to get them
communicating money and put it into a
bag and carry that with you okay we're
gonna we're gonna hunt down some pigs
open a far cry or you skin animals for a
coin first hitting the wrong button here
Oh
philanthropy says go back into the house
pick up that 1887 Oh which was your
house I want this one though what the
weird with the left for dead door where
is it there in did I miss it
can you wait can you interact with that
thing well there's this 1887 I don't
know uh right there the second one well
is it better yeah I just take it sure I
don't really want those but yeah let's
quit okay uh that's a board not a pig oh
it's a boar where's the pigs then right
what that looks like a pig to me I don't
know we'll find out hey Lowell this is
the curly little tail it's no that's not
for or it's not a pig and the thing said
big right pretty sure the thing said Pig
let's check oh we sure get the right
thing here yeah pig hide hey just the
same icon dude it's a pig oh yes this is
a cool little gun I loved in a blood
dragon you had a shotgun like this and
when you reload it he would do D
Terminator 2 thing where he would like
oh yeah that's right
oh really man yeah there was some cool
little touches in that game the dialogue
in the opening scene right just like
straight out of one of those 80s it's
like action when the ending the ending
is so so good and for the end credits of
that game they played the friends
forever which is from the hit eighties
movie Miami connections which I own on
blu-ray the iron sword
we're in pigs are basically the same
thing I mean once they're dead they're
kind of yeah I mean they they both make
bacon I guess oh my god these stupid dog
gang doses it could be a tapir I mean
you are in Africa almost sure I thought
we were done killing dogs yeah I thought
so too
that's critical pigs on dogs all right
almost there
here we go oh there they are
I reckon they're not going to attack you
right
they're just gonna run away let's get
them
mmm yeah one that's all you need right
just one yep guys we're just trying to
make a wallet I'm really just trying to
go wall here hold on come on we need to
get like upgrades going here okay
let's craft us a wallet what I don't
have it anymore
did I not keep it I think they just
stole it from you come on come on taking
the car um oh heck we are doing the
mission that is called building a new
wallet or just driving off this cliff
whoa your cars on fire John there's fine
no I thought that would work
headphones came off dang it all right uh
yeah Bobo we're not doing so well now
we're really not okay for a slide on
this we're inside this yep I'm gonna
hurt myself gonna fix my thumbs that I
broke I always liked those animations I
was watching them like it's pretty
brutal ones into you know like use a
knife to pull out arrows out or just
like crack your yak rocky road elbows
back into place yeah some good stuff
try this thing again
UTV see how I do oh it's a Supply Drop
yeah well you should I shouldn't
biohazard thing I shouldn't do that
though because I won't actually get the
money I just killed it actually I can't
I'm I'm I'm in the village do you do
that's not how thumbs work uh okay we're
is there to go here I'm heading to the
the actual mission of joke okay oops
well let's just keep doing that then if
we find a pig we'll kill it hope I can
find like a car or something
as Andrew Gogol do you prefer farcry
driving mechanics or GTA mechanics I
don't I don't like the driver in Far Cry
I'm not very good at it I also I'm not
good at driving in video games in
general though well I think just driving
in first person in video games is always
kind of tough absolutely if you can't
see the sides there we go okay
but I like I do like their commitment to
staying in first person sup dudes ok we
want to go this way oh no more trees oh
ok you're good you're upright and
there's a river crossing a river afford
it
oh dear nope
well that Plan C this is how are you you
just killed my lord my adventures go it
is a boat
you take that boat I've seen all the
booty picture in this stuff welcome to
the stream you just joined oh hello oh
yeah if you're just joining us by the
way we are streaming Far Cry 3 on pc
mortal also talking about Far Cry 5
which the trailer which was just
released this morning so if you have any
questions about the Far Cry series or
Far Cry 5 and specifically feel free to
ask and we're here for you oh is this
new island so not the second island but
just a little your little bits
Shane O'Neill is asking the Far Cry 5
will just be more of the same far cry
that's a good question that's kind of
it's really hard to say because they
only release the trailer that they
release is basically just talking about
the story um right and if you know the
Far Cry series you you can see that it's
still going like with some some of the
similar tropes in as far as the
characters go like the crazy antagonists
yeah I mean they're definitely gonna
continue that trend for sure which they
should but I hope that they do it better
let's get this tower ice also mentioned
killing a shark we could f initely try
and do that through a rock Jake rock set
farcry in a back backyard during the
tall his birthday party I'll play
anything in the series during whosever
that toddlers birthday party are you
playing a toddler this is like a rugrat
situation
okay you think you you thinking shank
some sharks shank some sharks head to
shank probably not or a grenade them
boobies even would be fun come on get
there everybody
is there another oh there you saw the
prompt all right that was screaming just
being weird do it it's easy all right
sure we could we could try oh okay uh
here we go
I found a stuff soap annoying Joshua
Pugin will it be the most controversial
game of this generation mmm interesting
question the whole thing about like them
doing like the whole religious cult
thing is pretty pretty interesting
because it we talked about in the office
and some of us were saying that it's a
situation that you could possibly see
happening in real life which is kind of
scary didn't they say they were inspired
by that thing that happened laughs here
yeah so there if you guys heard about
this there was a group of people part of
a militia in I think Oregon was it it
was Oregon or walk I believe I was
Oregon and they they were armed and they
took control of this uh it's like a
national park area whoo I just unlocked
a bunch of guns including a flamethrower
so we should go pick up that and it was
it was kind of a scary situation because
you know these people are like
unsupervised they have plenty of weapons
yeah like a what do you approach people
like that telling them that oh this is
you guys can't do this you can't do this
over any government property they had um
they were like live streaming on YouTube
I was wat and I was watching it it was
listening mostly it was like oh yeah big
live stream then they were live
streaming on YouTube that was I was
listening to it was pretty nuts
I want to I want to jump on that dude if
I can you know the occupation of Malheur
National Wildlife Refuge right okay I
got another new when was that but well
that was like late last year I thought
it was early last year Cameron it says
Tommy versus Angelica and farcry yeah
high six I'd like that
so there's I know you do this like jump
kill thing but that guys like too far
away for me to do that properly what if
I can
I forgot any skills I can uh no I got
some skill points really
yeah just for above uh yeah let's get
that Oh jump onto it jump all the people
yeah that thing oh that is some
compressed video let's see here um
produced a machine from explosions
sliding herbs swimming faster about that
uh Andrews asking do we like the UV saw
style of uncovering the map by climbing
towers that's not just you be something
anymore it's like an everything it's
also a Nintendo thing if you play breath
of the wild yeah I mean it's uh I didn't
mind it when I first came out like in
Far Cry 3 but now I'm just sort of like
a little over it I don't hate the idea
behind it it's more that when they
unveil the map they tend to have like a
very checklist II repetitive set of
objectives so yeah I kind of wanted them
to UM get away from me I could get this
guy that way look at think I feel like
I'll end up in a bad situation I do huh
yeah Joshua the religion politics are
kind of a tricky thing to approach
especially in video games well that I
work out oh good do you sure I was
trying alright so hard jump on boom
supposed to be stealthy here I tried
real hard didn't work out oh they got
alarm going off oh never cave oh hey
what's up
please die on what are your wallets well
you never upgraded that pig wallet and
they took my they took my pig skin hello
dudes alright
signs pistols useless stuff I get aside
to rant he remembers no Russian beam was
like one of the ho s controversial sure
sure or controversial scenes in Italy
right the whole hot coffee mod in oh
yeah andreas ever that like those things
yeah they're they're like but they're I
feel like they were a concert
controversial for very like very
different reasons that far cry 5 rights
rise when you're dealing with like you
know religion it it can help it's like a
lot more touchy I think I I would tend
to agree for sure because like violence
in video games and sexy cutting they're
kind of all over the place in lots of
like modern shooters and you know mature
games so to speak yeah like the hot
coffee mod and then the you know Russian
are not really really better they're
kind of laughable now yeah good way
but at the very least hot coffee I mean
yeah I'm doing it with jeans on come on
sure yeah the hawk everyone's definitely
laugh with the the no Russian one it's
not laughable no like haha that's funny
but more like it's not quite as edgy as
it seems like back then it felt like
whoa right but now you're like oh sorry
that it feels like the try me yeah um
but one thing I don't everything's on
fire well also everyone's dead so you're
good what one person not everyone one
thing I thought about was BioShock
Infinite and kind of like a way that
they approached religion in that game
right it's somewhat similar in the idea
that there's like this guy who's trying
to lead this cult into lecture world of
you know Columbia up in the sky is about
religion um but where is like BioShock
Infinite was very fantastical like a
flaw with a flying City and everything
no more this went like feels low profile
kind of hits pretty close to home right
literally being like in America yeah
that the idea that it could happen yeah
I mean that's what potentially could set
it apart from the other far cry games is
you know these always there's that
disconnect of like oh this happens on
some weird island off the coast of
Africa no reason for me to like ever
likely really think about or worry about
things like this happening
totally like drug-drug lures and like
five ten thousand miles away from me
that's fine yeah exactly
Peggy 18 says talked about mature games
to I'm here nice thanks Peggy eighteen
thanks for all your work all your hard
work even rebel gaming says you may have
started a fire here yeah just a little
bit uh-oh here we go
yeah game really hit that guy so I
wonder if like far am I've will like
deal with like drugs for example
oh I'm surely I don't know what the
story will be with that game in like why
these people are like holding these like
town goers hostage and trying to convert
them whatever right like yeah is there
like an ulterior motive
yeah day like really crazy like do they
want the end of the world or is it like
yeah like they also turn like get money
or you know the iron sword as far as we
know you can customize your character um
there was some speculation in the
trailer like some of the some of the
people fighting against the bad guys
were like your quote-unquote your
character don't kill him I was about say
line don't kill the tiger I leave mom if
he kills me that oh that's on you oh no
ask what happened
oh here's boss here he is
okay we got some Boston it's nacho for
me mm-hmm I'll turn it up a little bit
ask you a question give you Gary no
forgive me daddy
my sister give you daddy huh I think I
miss you one of us
you think that means you like me huh
California bully's got a hard on jungle
fever
I'm gonna drive a bullet through my
sister's skull I need you brother grant
[ __ ] you were angry Jason
her angry
get that
I get it
we're family
there was none where I do anything to my
sister and the first time I ever killed
was for my sister
not enough for her no no penis she don't
think about our loved ones right my
[ __ ] loved ones they commonly fry
inside Ruby [ __ ] time
listen to me they say boss what who the
[ __ ] is it going to be done hey why I
can like like you look like they [ __ ]
think that I need to make a [ __ ]
choice by the way this letter really
sucks you know so much for boy dicks
it's really too bad
that's it right don't you are there's
not even a way to kill you still wish
okay
okay Jason
I swear to god man it's truly beautiful
you're willing to die for the one you
love
[Music]
think of rum bad
yeah Michael mando is so good mmm
yeah like I didn't even know about him
before like watching bear across all I
like he in that show he's just so
intense like there is a scene that goes
on like with him David I mean he really
like steals the show in this game and
seems like this are like really good but
they happen so infrequently the solution
is to shoot things DJ - yeah we're just
letting the person Mack play out because
you know people just love that character
also is good opportunity for me my back
home okay alright and dope I create a
thing
Cameron's asking what Indian did you
take the first time through the leave
with my friends ending and then I looked
up the you have sex and then get
sacrificed ending with weird this game
story goes it gets really bad at the end
I can Billy wasn't like that great it's
really just like Foss is what makes the
story great like the actual narrative is
like pretty
it looks like the fire spread a tiny bit
I have that fire from earlier whoops
yeah whatever
oh my god jump Oh
what was your plan there just go just
plant face-first into all these banks
I'm just like really stupid she didn't
really jump I wasn't that far either get
it done that
Andrew Gogol brutal animations or soft
animations while killing which is
preferred I think we mean as far as them
like like really like messed up like oh
no I got brutal of course yeah wasn't
what kind of question is that
just kidding you prefer the brutal I
mean those are always more entertaining
right right yeah for sure
I am eating the button okay you chill
all right I assume I'm gonna get chased
and then I'm give me a gun well some
people with the the game volume up a
little bit oh sure
whoo I'm the de Namur
maybe a little close to myself it's just
encouraging her
DJ Nash with more more Michael mando
trivia he's saying that boss was
actually modeled after his audition and
that wasn't actually the character that
he auditioned for but you saw like them
what he what they liked his work so much
that they created him create that
character just for him that's awesome
I know her there's a similar good story
with Troy Baker where I guess like they
just trigger came in a sign for the
character and they were like all right
like kind of give this idea what kind of
character had and fertile Joaquin was us
for a for for for picking men okay and
he started I guess he just kind of
started acting and then all of a sudden
this woman comes in like like the
secretary something like give them
coffee and he just like starts like
talking to her and like he's like no no
Lisa lately at least leave the coffee
and he's just like harassing her and it
was like like in character and I mean
probably freaked the [ __ ] out of her but
uh apparently they're all like this is
yes perfect like a little weird her ass
that fat poor woman giving everyone
coffee but apparently it was a really
good performer those always the best
auditions right yeah
yeah yes walk over to that barrel please
oh come on
so lie I know
Oh conveniently after I killed them
serpentine why is he yeah what was I
believe I just like back and forth right
is that what separate like like strafing
is that also serpentine so he's barely
like turpentine its serpentine isn't it
could be wrong you can just say zigzag
yeah like she knows what serpentine
means right she's not too happy almost
being killed or sold into slavery
okay listen I'm fixing this do you know
where the Pirates took the others Keith
Daisy what about Riley I don't know
anything about Riley or grant it's dead
you do yeah when the Buddhist is a side
to side but he isn't that flies you have
to say certain teen ways serpentine no
fusion says guy subscribe absolutely
absolutely you can of course always
subscribe so you can see more great live
streams like this one yeah and uh
actually if you guys are going to be a
tune in later today we're going to a
couple more live streams for us at two
o'clock we'll have a Tekken 7 live
stream which will be playing on the
cabinets as well as having a couple
people from Bandai Namco and a pro
player by the name of mr. Knapp to join
us and then later in the day
we're gonna be streaming the arms test
punch light or we're gonna be streaming
the test punch demo that Nintendo is
releasing then so I think we're gonna be
there I think I will be there on both of
them
oh I guess I have to do this oh wait
when did you get this hotel I just like
this little area there's like a dude who
[Music]
is here um what is it there's like I
yeah there's like a cube right here how
I meant to do that who just walked
mm-hmm okay my arm is just oh it's fine
fine
Tim classist is hi hello sada livestream
the messed up pcs diz says do you like
picking me nervous I think we like Voss
more the very least you like the actor
for fossil yeah he's really good kinda
looks like a off-brand uh Elena
yeah oxy like she's in this game got
this like we're the exact same outfit
someone yeah okay that's not a hotel
just drug makers house I guess I gotta
do this whole thing it's gonna just want
to get my skin my wallet it's all I care
about
other pigs down here no probably not
find those vines I'm going the right way
I'm really not sure where are you going
in I guess that way but you sure go
around well there's this path is here
for a reason I guess right yeah good
thing okay okay we're going around lose
James is asking who I'm gonna be
fighting on arms I hope you mean other
people I'll answer both I think Nick
margarita a Rob handler II and I forgot
who we're gonna have one more person on
the stream I'm not sure Mike
yeah well we'll be all punching each
other but if you if you guys have seen
the game the all the characters look
pretty cool I think there's a bear here
oh yeah there's the bear there's no
we're thing Oh God
oh geez oh boy can I ask where that bear
came from oh no did you just fall
shotgun being killed the bear I did not
see that bear in the cave I'll have to
go all the way man
you swim over those wrongs you just swim
to it also I have it in my shotgun I
have this though okay let's just try
this way
I'm sorry interrupted you though you
were talking about you're gonna play in
arms yeah uh well as far as the
characters go I think uh well have you
seen like all the characters yet a
couple of them I saw DNA man oh yeah
he's really cool it looks but the one I
like is a Mechanica okay like she
doesn't actually have like the three
yarns but she has a sheep eyelets a
robot that does somebody's I always like
like girls in like a giant neck robots I
was kidding I always find it seem that
those are the characters I play in
fighting games I like the ramen noodle
girl because her arms are like ramen
noodles yeah it's funny because I I was
thinking like dude they've got to have
like DLC characters like in the future
right like I will just want to write
show anymore how many more different
kinds of characters can they make like
with like the themed arms like their
Springs or DNA helixes there's ramen
like what else is there who's got me
more right yeah um oh no no what they
currently have I think about what I mean
I just like food based uh he characters
it's a good premise yeah the messed up
PC says did you guys like Far Cry fives
trailer I actually really liked it yeah
I liked it quite a bit um and in
addition to that I think the oh there's
a bear the individual character
vignettes were like they have like the
interviews with the characters the main
three those are actually really good to
do like I think they set up the story a
lot better than just the trailer
yeah that bear is hella dad
the ramen girl aka min min beerus can
what can I make with a pair he's like a
bear wallet that'd be nice sadly now
it's a shark skin no leopard can be
giving with bears ammo pouch buffalo go
go boar
our boars and pigs those boars is pigs
as tape years there's dears but none of
which nothing with another thing that
you can craft high yet and it needs the
bare skin
so it's my objective here even let's try
to like find a light or something I'm
trying to light this cave up
hmm a merman says just make a bear bag
bear bag just take the body and just
track it drag it around put all your
stuff in there I'm sure eventually we'll
find a recipe well there's the relic and
this was just for the round something
out of a bear I think maybe I just have
to swim yeah that's what it is just down
there yeah also aha
that's what I needed you can drill okay
good we didn't kill a bear so you know
pretty good
hey if I can skip these I just really
don't care about carrying it like this
character stuff nothing can't hold me Oh
me doesn't see my up saying it's gonna
make me do a thing
probably anyway any more questions
ah see the mess apiece is asking about
Far Cry fives minimum specs oh that's
kind of hard to say since the you know
we haven't seen any actual gameplay well
they sure gave me I mean they showed in
game yes definitely pretty darn good so
the whole trailer is supposedly made
from their in-game engine um as far as
like what it's running on yeah it's
really hard to say but I mean you can
probably just look at recent Ubisoft
games and see how like the specs that
they've run like something like
wildlands right somewhat similar like if
you have a PC that can run that many
gigabytes do you think the game's gonna
babe Oh a lot thirty they're getting
bigger yeah I think a four was like 26 I
was looking at it earlier this is only
like 10 Andrew Google says when will the
stream end we got wrap up by 12:30 at
the ladies yeah so another another half
an hour we're gonna we're definitely
gonna punch a bear or no we're gonna
punch a shark shark we're gonna get our
need a shark grenade a shark we're gonna
kill a shark by any means necessary
we're gonna get a pigskin okay I think
that's our goals here
Far Cry VR ooh that'd be fun
I don't know like an entire game maybe a
maybe not but like I mean I applied all
Resident Evil and they are just like
build some exotic location like we're
okay if they made a far cry VR where
would you want it to be in like what
country if it's VR yeah or maybe just
like for the next one if they were to go
somewhere like anywhere go somewhere
else exotic um but no knowing that they
have VR in that game as well hmm if the
VR necessarily influences this but I
still haven't seen many games actually
take place in China it's true and I
would like to see more of that like that
I feel like there's a lot of potential
in China it's just that I feel like it's
very tricky to portray sure I mean
unless you go like ancient China which
is always fun to look yeah or just like
world China right okay we're going here
that's always like the question with
like like where the next Assassin's
Creed take place in because they're
always like jumpy for plays plays or the
next GTA they never did that Assassin's
Creed Japan that I was wanting well did
they do those like side-scroller ones
yeah that was in China where it wasn't
showing you the - I always wanted was
Japan they still haven't done and the
French Revolution which they did do but
at that point I didn't care about
Assassin's Creed anymore so that game
was apparently really buggy and not very
good so it was a real bummer cuz I I was
like yay oh I don't care actually
anymore that's a that's a disappointment
djanet is also mentioning the Resident
Evil they did it they made the whole
game in view yeah exactly I delayed that
whole game in fear same here it's really
good however I'll say that game worked
really well in VR because it's in the
dark yeah and a lot slower than this
this might potentially make it sick yeah
you would have to change the way Far Cry
operates too
work in VR without making you horribly
ill
I I quite like to resin even Br
get to these hey like afar crying like a
snowy area
oh I actually know the Himalayas
Himalayas kind of did it although it
wasn't like the whole thing was in the
snowy area or like a desert knows to
what what else could they do then
there's dudes there dang it they're
gonna hear me what kind of impacts
Paolini you just leave one right
Pig hide simple wallet ready to craft
it's finally yes and a rugged wallet we
some cassowaries man it's such a bummer
though because there's all that chance
to get money that I don't have yeah all
right so we could hit that next up is
the shark gars ultishark oh I knew it a
desert would be fun though
I like desert yeah like not not not like
a savanna right but like actual desert
oh yeah like the Sahara yeah I was just
looking at up the UH I think it said the
next upgrade for the wallet needs
cassowaries mm-hmm and apparently I
remember this little little piece of
trivia that cap apparently cassowaries
are the most dangerous birds in the
entire world really yeah because they're
like I think they're close like they
they're similar to ostriches where
they're huge and they're kind of bulky
they can't fly I think but they're like
five feet tall and they're like
incredibly strong and their claws are
like this long and will like shred
humans like flesh like just like that
they also sound insane - somebody said
FarCry in space we're all game
franchises go to die yeah on the moon
Duda
I don't know anybody died the best
franchises thrive in space Friday the
13th
uh I that's the only I could think of
5:15
we were talking about how disappointed
I was disappointed that they do not have
a Jason X scan in the front of 13th game
dlc set it like get get a set it in a
space station with uh and then you could
you could do like your look astronauts
oh my god that way you could do some
really there's a really good kill where
someone gets like cryogenically frozen
and then just like smashes their head
and like that was a really good one you
do some good stuff in that game we can
call a nice planets and far cry
would you call it Far Cry primal was in
in 10,000 BC Far Cry future now how I
use the word future Far Cry mmm-hmm we
need some we need some ideas where space
is space word you can attach to Far Cry
just put in space far great space
machete in space yes machete in space
that was a good one here watching the
machete movies no I did I just know that
they're like pretty ridiculous pretty
good yeah I quite enjoyed both of them a
lot like no one saw the second one
actually in the I saw with my cousin in
the theater and we were the only two
there we're really excited like yeah me
too
we until then this other family comes in
that's a famous and like a family for
quite Infinite and we were infinite
that's that's a good one
we were loving the movie were laughing
cuz we're just like man this movie so
dumb via I don't think the family really
knew what they were getting into
do they accidentally walk in there or
like I think they thought it was gonna
be a little more serious because they
hated thank you or the movies called
machete machete kills yo again or
something like that right like like they
they clearly did not know what they were
getting into
okay we need actual both though is the
thing cuz I can't reach oh I've ought to
keep people saying [ __ ] right Nuva Far
Cry Andromeda Mark Ryan Arkin who's for
Craig Vance far cry Nexus what up goob
goob joined us boys here we're trying to
punch a shark or something I don't know
now wait a shirt grenade a shark or that
way can you see them from here
like can you throw some like weight yes
yes Jun there's one there's one I see it
I see it
need it okay actually I don't think I
have any grenades far far away cried oh
he's close enough I don't touch it no
you have to like I can help him
yeah okay we're going for stellar GaN
part we're gonna get a C cup you're
gonna be the one to sneak up on the
third oh they didn't work just okay
can't knife in the water this isn't
gonna work some jellyfish they're right
they'll probably sting me okay you
cannot whoa whoa whoa
get them ah they're not natural is it
these are the new types of flying fish
here what do you think I can make out of
those with their skin apparently we've
already unlocked the the Far Cry
Andromeda mod here nice are you dang at
the shark swim away I can't shoot him
anymore neither am mi or m1 hello from
Tunisia
that's really far hello ooh another
shark I don't think you're oh no shark
I feel like know that these are working
by hitting them
I think bullets go up to like two feet
in the water in real life aah dang it
aah
that fish a.i okay we need that boat
because I need to when you're in the
boat whoa
a crab kill it what nothing on this
island should survive there it is
can't skin a picky little monster so oh
it's a castle where you got the bird huh
kill it
it's good oh my God look at it
can you see its talons because those
things are crazy we try and look okay
maybe they're not so obvious here but
yeah they might who knows how things are
ridiculously scary okay so we need a
boat I wish kill another one we needed
to foil over the wall under fill' Julie
oh god suck it not so tough now with
bullets ah okay no that's tough tough
tough tough tough tough tough far sky
far sky no far sky okay I can make
another one out
who sharkskin for the heavy-duty wallet
nice smacks on our wallet here okay I
shouldn't look like that or should it
with a boat
now the the look at the mountain yeah
like that doesn't look right
I'm sure it's not a gap like maybe it is
but it is the water served itself
through it maybe it's no it's just
loading no no there is supposed to be a
hole again but it's really weird
okay might want to steal that boat yeah
we need to I kind of maybe I can like
crash into them you can't drive on these
jet skis
well that boat son Thunder God those
birds are really scary was that a better
boat what's about that's unattended oh
cool
although I'm now I'm being shot by that
other boat guys guys oh no no I just
want to kill a shark and your brown ass
how long till peta file is a complaint I
mean the fire games have been going on
for quite a while okay we're gonna go to
this town we're going to equip up on
ammo get our grenades we're gonna murder
some sharks that'll be of your final run
maybe it's like we're right a bit low on
time but still got time for some shark
murder yeah okay we're good clean barlas
says running over with the jet ski I
don't know if we can I'm well I'm
willing to try I'm willing to go there's
enough power in the jet ski to kill it
though it's also really low I mean you
may be like break its fin probably piss
it off a lot goop says you miss all the
far cry 5 talk give them some highlights
well we talked about the just the
controversial aspect of it I like just
games don't really go into religion all
that much and the ones that do they have
been pretty good like you know BioShock
Infinite I'm not I can't unblinking on
any other ones that have like attempted
to have some sort of commentary on that
as far as mainstream games go yeah I'm
struggling a thing penny oh but yeah you
know it could possibly be
could possibly ruffle some feathers if
it's not doing that already right it
could be pretty good it could be
we'll see depends on how they handle it
yeah
okay we will attempt to drive over them
first let's test this out gotta find
them there's one
stay on target oh hey was that one that
me a word sounded like some it sounds
very wooden where's his body I see the
fish down there though
should I go under and look oh it's under
me I'm gonna check how do you get how to
get under here there we go yeah wow that
works hello you can skin it yeah that'd
be incredibly tough to do underwater
like the heavy-duty holster oh we cannot
carry four weapons at the same time
perfect cool yes a diabolical the reveal
trailer wasn't quite the UH or he says
like the trailer wasn't actual graphics
like it's right right not it was in
engine type of thing so they're using
it's not like a fully render like
cutscene but it's not necessarily what
they'll make what though the game will
end up looking like when you're playing
it right like well definitely though
some say those vignettes for example
yeah definitely not look like a DJ now
she's taken off so thanks so much for
answering questions yeah glad to have
you on the stream dude what do we do now
we like ran over a shark well I
suggested the grenade but since you
don't have any we're gonna do I have
some grenades we have we can try and
kill another one okay one we just want
to try some more shark myths here also
it's just one of these guys
tynix I need a boat anyone got a boat
oh I'll lose James has fallen always had
religious cults yeah that is true but
like as far as I have them be so
prominent in this like be the main
antagonist in the storyline and have it
be so very similar to like or not
similar but just have it be kind of a
lot more realistic most of all it's uh
cults and religious calls for like
fictional cults that certainly took
influence from cults but this is more
like actually based on like Christianity
and stuff like that it's a little bit
destroying a little bit more touchy
subject may be low muhammad ya wee oh
wee he's saying we should have played
far cry 4 well you know we I think do we
have some problems we were we were
having problems we were going back and
forth between whether we were going to
play three or four a lot of people seem
to one three based on Twitter poll but a
lot of people also wrote in for for
unfortunate we could only have four
choices for the little bit Cole right
yeah that was part of the issue why we
didn't have four on there was uh you're
limited on the poll
mister PC says third person far cry
comments hmm I like far cry first person
I mean if God makes it oh yeah here we
go finally putting that skill to use yes
I mean like if it was third person it
would kind of be like just another kind
of like this would probably be similar
to like wildlands possibly right or like
just cause they know just being in you
know just cause it's probably better
yeah okay like without the M you know
like crazy grappling-hook thing yeah I
think like it has an identity as a
first-person shooter
so it says apparently far cry 3 is what
birth jacksepticeye I get I guess that's
like the first game he played for
something oh really that's what I what
someone's saying that's awesome and you
go cool thanks for tuning in
then we'll see you next time hope you
enjoyed the stream and hope you tune in
for some of the other ones too thanks
that's true ls2 had a religious scholar
I think that came up it might just be
the year or religious a season of
religious cult games wonder why well I
mean outlast kind of did they have much
of that in the first game I don't
remember
now the first game was more weird like
science experiments from what I remember
I'm sure it had some colder stuff in it
I don't recall take that boat hey it's a
shark
they just beached or something yeah and
now he's dead
all these bullet holes on there we go
so I want to know what time that Tekken
stream is it's taking over at 2 p.m.
yeah yeah it's 2 to 2 p.m. Pacific is
that a 5 right yeah arms will be a 5 Bob
Jensen I want more dinosaur games uh
yeah dude every every Thursday Peter and
always the same Bob Jones I've been
calling him Bobo I'm very sorry by the
way I don't have my glasses on so I
can't really text is a little small yes
we will get you more dinosaur games next
week on Thursdays we will have a another
Dino Dino DNA I'm not sure when our
playing next week I think they might
they said there might they might uh go a
little more modern because they played
turoff to yesterday yeah but strong like
98 didn't really work out for them that
well ok
there was no explosion but that shark
did indeed die I think you sure you
didn't just hit him with a grenade said
yes goob I cannot read I'm sorry
scanning sharks come on mr. PC thanks
for watching okay how much time do we
got left Joey you got about five minutes
all right what we do in five minutes uh
where can we what can we do
is that a race yeah I'll be terrible at
let's do it okay let's try and get to
that race we killed mr. Krabs can you
feel it now mr. Krabs
philanthropy says we should just have
the whole office play Dino d-day next
week
oh yes what is that is it I think that
is it what I'm thinking it is a
multiplayer shooter with Dinosaurs and
like well what you are dinosaurs yeah I
think it's like dinosaurs on world war
ii 'the themed if i recall i would like
to play i think they're not see
dinosaurs sir i need to accommodate your
vehicle oh I don't have a repair kit
okay never mind
no I don't want to talk to you dude I
need a ways I need another car are you
looking up again I'm looking up that I
think I mentioned to you last week that
dinosaur asthma game oh yeah that they
should like okay it's called bronchial
sores he's here to teach you about
bronchitis and about I think it's like
you know it's an anti-smoking game from
like a year was this goes for the Super
Nintendo in 95 and it's like one of
those edutainment
former games you know they were all the
regions right yeah I'm playing like some
anti-smoking games yeah so I'll bring
that up to to Peter and Rob further
their stream eventually all right I'm
gonna I'm a novice racer lady Murphy hi
sorry we only have about five minutes
left on the stream but if you want to
watch the rest of it you can score back
a little bit see us grenade some sharks
and have a little meet up with boss
earlier oh here it is race racin I'll do
okay no you're missing oh I got rice
almost missed it caboose we are playing
on PC and surprisingly a lot of people
have mentioned the game stole holds up
pretty well
graphically wise yeah absolutely okay
it's a lot of checkpoints here oh I
don't want to run you over please move
Oh like you ha I'm so sorry it's worth
it for sometime sometimes when you race
you just have to take a couple lives
that's all I mean what I bet fifty bucks
on this thing yeah that's worth it
wait how much do you get if you win I
guess double cuz I think I was like eh
yeah definitely worth it yeah hundred
bucks or another fifty bucks
yeah see I got 100 bucks yes so we're
the little bloodshed okay cool I think
it's gonna wrap up our our stream we
have the Far Cry 3 talking about Far Cry
5 is that the name of Lee I think that
was the official title I'm not mistaken
thanks des playing far cry 3 well
talking about far cry 5 so I mean I hope
you guys enjoyed it we will have again
we will have a couple more streams going
on later today at 2 p.m. we will have
the Tekken 7 stream yeah and at 5 p.m.
we will have the armed stream yes so
stay tuned for those and remember to go
check out our channel on games or tennis
ball calm and also the youtube and
twitch we have a trailer breakdown of
the Far Cry 5 yep trailer um that our
miguel concepción did i'm so go check
that out and we will see you next week
oh and next Friday what are we playing
another J and J stream no idea but we'll
be here next Friday playing a game as
always all right I see you guys later